okay so the staging area would get it's
really helpful and really powerful I
think I try to use it in a way where
I've just only written the things that I
actually want to commit and all I have
to do is stage them and commit it but in
practice things get a little messier
than that so I think the common pattern
for me is I do one thing and then in the
process I accidently do something else
and then I'll use the staging area to
help me just stage the first thing and
commit that and then if I'm ready to
commit the second thing I can if I'm not
I can keep working on it
but it's just a really helpful tool to
make sure that your commits are only the
thing that you actually meant to commit
even though probably along the way you
did a lot of other things so for my own
projects I probably won't have that many
branches if if it's simple enough I'll
even just have one the main thing that
I'll just be doing is committing as
often as I possibly can
I'll try and just whenever I think that
I've accomplished anything that I can
call a commit that I can call a single
unit of work I'll just commit that and
it does lead to having probably a lot
more commits than you ultimately need to
look back at but at the same time
there's going to be a handful of them
that you really want because you want to
undo that one thing or you want to just
see why you did that one thing and it's
just really really valuable for those
commits to be able to have them and not
have them jumbled up with other things
so committing really really often is the
most important thing for me